[Applause]
try to avoid
bad packaging that's obviously one of
the major things try to buy food that
has been grown locally as much as you
possibly can to collapse those food
miles behind me is one vertical farm
tower it is five and a half meters high
we can put these things on brownfield
unwanted unusable land uh you know old
industrial sites edge of an airport you
know something like like that but
crucially we put it right next to the
point of production or consumption which
means that we're going to be able to
collapse the food miles
17
of food available to consumers is thrown
away
i've got two top tips for anyone who's
interested in living a more waste free
life the first one is do things one by
one go through your house and when
things run out whether it's toothpaste
shampoo or pasta try and find an
alternative where you can find it
completely waste free or limiting the
amount of single-use plastic you have my
other great tip for people is something
that i did myself which is a waste audit
and i promise you it's more fun than it
sounds what you have to do is you have
to collect up your waste for two or
three weeks and after that time look
through it find what items you have in
there there might be something that is
taking up more of your waste than others
and go through it systematically for me
when i did it as a student i had a lot
of meal deal wrappers so the first thing
i tackled was making my own lunches
spend
your time and money and effort on
making the envelope of the building as
good as it possibly can be use more
insulation get triple glazed windows if
you can
passive house has been designed
intentionally to have as much
insulation as possible
and
to use
orientation
if we use timber from sustainably
managed forests so for every tree that
is cut down
19 new trees are planted those trees as
they grow absorb carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere if we harvest them carefully
and turn them into construction timber
then we can capture that carbon from the
atmosphere and keep it locked in
the building
for the duration of that building's
lifespan within the fabric of this
building we have stored 50 tonnes of
carbon during construction we have
emitted 25 tonnes we've stored more
carbon than we've produced at the moment
we need to build
350 000
new houses per year to meet current
demand
and if we carry on building them the way
that we're building them just now
so business as usual
we have
no hope in hell of meeting the
climate targets that our governments
have set for us
[Music]
you